alright guys I just got my order of the
V cube 5 that I got from V cubes calm
I ordered it three days ago and I just
got it today so the shipping and
processing was a lot quicker than my V
cube six and seven order that I placed a
few months ago back when I first placed
that order that's when the V cubes had
just come out so I'm sure that there was
a lot of demand for the V cubes at that
point which is why the shipping took so
long they were also using DHL back when
I first placed the order and now they
are using UPS so that could have
something to do with it as well the
shipping of the V cubes had went down a
lot which is one of the reasons why I
bought it now I paid about $50 with just
the V cube 5 which is still pretty
expensive but it's a lot cheaper than
what I would have paid back when I
ordered the B cube 6 and 7 they also
offer a package that comes with the V
cube 5 6 & 7
the complete collection now from the V
Cube website so what I'd like to do now
is just basically do an unboxing video
and also give a short review of the V
cube 5 as far as the structure the
stability the smoothness of it similar
to what I did for the V Cube 6 and 7 in
my other review so let's open the V Cube
5 the package
scissors came apart that's great so
there you have it the V cube 5 back when
I got it from DHL that V cube 6 & 7 this
was basically just in a bag so now the
shipping is a little bit better they put
some bubble wrap as well to keep it
protected so I'm going to basically just
you know break it in a little bit try it
out and then I will give a short review
of the ups and downs of the V cube 5 as
well
staring down at the v-cube 5 which is
still wrapped in this magnificent sky
blue box that is wrapped in this
beautiful plastic I realized that I did
not truly take the v-cube 5 out of the
box I would have put it on video had I
had this brilliant idea before but what
I must do now is to surgically remove
the vacuum from the box so that we can
cut the plastic and take it out of the
box so we can have a closer look at it
so I'm going to do that now I made an
incision and you can see on the right
side of the box and then I put my hand
in and I pull now you could see I have a
V tube v in my hand what I'm going to do
now then is to take a closer look at the
vq v and see if there are any
imperfections and then give it a little
test run then we can continue with the
review thank you very much for watching
all right so the v-cube five ways of
a half a pound which is pretty close to
the weight of a new retooled professor
cube
the professor cube is a little bit
bigger than the vq5 the vq5 is about the
same size as a 4x4 Rubik's Cube revenge
I did purchase the white V Cube v they
also offer a black V Cube v but I had
the white V Cube 6 and 7 so the white V
Cube 5 has the white plastic and
opposite yellow stickers you have black
stickers instead of white the color
scheme on the rest of the cube however
is the same as the Rubik's franso
opposite blue you have the green
opposite red you have the orange and
opposite yellow as I said we have the
black one of the major differences
between a V Cube v and a Rubik's or each
teen brand is that at the core of the V
Cube v there is an access piece which is
basically the same as a 3 by 3 access
piece it has the center supports which
are attached to the axis piece by
Springs so what that means is that the V
Cube v has a lot of flexibility to these
layers and that allows it to cut corners
very well and also to move more easily
the East Sheen and rubik's brands are a
little bit more rigid since they don't
have springs as far as turning is
concerned the V Cube 5 layers turn very
smoothly
the outer layers do have a type of
clicky feel but it's really not
noticeable when your speed solving
there is a little bit more resistance in
a V Cube v than say an East Chien cube
you can pretty much turn the East in
cube layers with one finger but the
thing about the East gene cube is that
it tends to lock up it tends to lock up
a lot more because there's no spring
inside so each of these pieces is
basically held together by friction and
that doesn't let it cut corners very
well either so the inner layers of the
vq5 also trying extremely well which is
important for solving the center's so
overall the cube feels very stable it's
solid and it's durable when I was
solving the vq5 and I solved it about 25
times now I really wasn't worried about
the cube locking up or having the pieces
pop out after only a few sobs I was able
to beat my record on the other cube on
the East gene cube which was originally
three minutes and 54 seconds I was able
to beat it by almost 30 seconds within
an hour of solving the V Cube five so
the cube did occasionally jam up but
that's because I was trying to do
something like that
it was basically my fault so overall I
think this is a great speed cube I think
that the V Cube 5 is very similar to a V
Cube 7 it turns just as good both are
very close in quality and stability and
have very few problems I would
definitely say that the vq5 is worth of
I if you want to get faster and if you
want to have a reliable and sturdy cube
so I will be releasing a V Cube 5 speed
solve video soon
so be sure to check it out thank you
very much for watching and please
subscribe for a notification of my
videos take care